so restless Evan the band footage DLC is
out how many days after release like a
week one week yes and I know it's
actually it is crazy how fast it was
because I don't even like I know a lot
of people haven't finished the game yet
like you were saying you need to finish
it still right yeah yeah same with you
and we I beat it a while ago a couple
days before it released and I liked it a
lot I want to replay it in mad house
mode John Luke's been doing that he's
playing in VR which is crazy to me he
played through the entire game in VR but
um which apparently you can for this for
this game it's really the RS great in
this game but we I played the band
footage so if you guys had questions I
feel like oh yeah we got a lot of
questions through twitch if you are
sorry Twitter if you're in Twitter
YouTube and have questions feel free to
curl them my way so just to preface it
quick nightmare is one of the tapes
that's essentially like a survival run
in the basement from web played you can
unlock a heart or difficulty but you
essentially just run around the basement
trying to survive like five waves of
molded and crawlers and I don't want to
boil too much but there are other kind
of like mini bosses involved but you're
collecting you're finding these
compactors that you turn on for scrap
and how it works is you're kind of
trying to unlock more the basement so
you can loop around but to do that you
need to buy like these corrosive things
to melt these locks and then you you
know you just kind of say do I want to
buy a handgun or do I want to upgrade my
health or do I want to buy the m37
shotgun or flame rounds or of course you
know first aid but you're also kind of
trying to find these compactors they
like slowly deal out increments of 100
scrap which you're using to buy these as
you can see here but you are essentially
just trying to you're surviving right
but it's at a certain point that
compactors will stop giving you scraps
so then you just kind of have to fight
with what you've got I got to the last
[ __ ] enemy on wave five and died so
they compactor right here you can catch
you're watching this you can kind of see
it will get to 100 then you can pick it
up right there this is my footage so
it's not judge me too harshly but yeah
the survivors will gone till about 5
a.m. and I got to like for whatever was
the last enemy and it killed me yeah it
sucked but there is also the bedroom
tape that comes with the
footage DLC and this is more of an
escape room based around Marguerite's
the matriarch of the Baker family she
essentially you wake up and you're you
you were watching me play it creepy
Marguerite's nuts but you're you you're
up to the bed
and you are essentially it's got a cool
angle I don't want to spoil too much but
I do think it's cool you're Jake Decker
and John looked at a stream yesterday so
there's a lot of stuff to do in the room
to escape it obviously but also if she
hears something loud she will come back
into the room so the twist is before she
comes back you have to like reset
everything you did or as much as
possible so she doesn't see that you're
out of bed and kill you you have to get
back in bed and like handcuff yourself
again so she doesn't notice it's pretty
creepy it adds like a really cool tense
layer to it or it's awesome I really
like this escape from um I think too
much of it is kind of that the pitfall
that a lot of like point click
adventures fall into where after a
certain point I wasn't really solving it
possible I was just like scanning the
environment inch by inch to try to find
something I could interact with jean-luc
can have as much trouble as I did I
think maybe I just had just played
nightmare so I wasn't paying too much
attention to details but the DLC is very
good at ten dollars they have another
one confirmed and then the season pass
that was thirty dollars so in order for
that to make sense there has to be at
least like two more DLCs which they're
both going to be ten dollars because
it's not even a deal if there's not
going to be three that's thirty dollars
that makes sense what I have a couple
questions what uh I guess without
spoiling anything are you playing as
someone that's not Ethan is the the idea
being I'm like a different timeline so
it's it's the clampy Jarvis timeline if
you play the game he is the cameraman
for the that show okay so it's
essentially if you played the beginning
our demo there's a certain point where
he gets knocked out it's pretty much
between that and then between this other
thing that happened later in resonable
seven without spoiling so you're will
have two Jarvis - cameraman alright I
think that does that make sense you guys
are as you are in the oh yeah cool so I
don't spoil that but yes you're
clenching Jarvis and then the basements
the same layout as it is in the game yes
anything you can do in PR
yes the are compatible but apparent
Ethan must die mode is also including
this and it's harder than madhouse
apparently he can take like no damage at
all I didn't get the chance to play it
but a lot of people they just said
there's a there's a hard-as-nails quote
unquote Ethan must die mode
and I didn't get a chance buddy but
madhouse is already hard as hell John
Luke was playing it and it was just like
jack just warped around different things
having different points I doesn't
deserve in different places and yes like
enemies are just tougher in general but
it essentially just sounds like Ethan
must die is even harder which I don't
know we're going to get our next segment
actually we're going to get into like
games that are better on their hardest
difficulty
I don't think resonable 7 is but there
are games but each must die kind of
sounds like maybe a third playthrough
difficulty if you want to give that it's
kind of interesting how like I mean how
I'm seeing it just because this DLC is
kind of different right like it's like
men for replayability I wonder if it'll
do something as different for the next
one or will it be like another type of
like survival thing I don't know right
because the yet it's a cool blend right
it's just a new mode which is good
enough that could have been the update
but then there's the escape room which
is more puzzle based and kind of this
tension but then there's the nightmare
which is more combat oriented and
survival focus I liked nightmare a lot I
actually want to play keep playing I did
like four runs errs and like the closest
I got was my first one so you have to
pick between the shotgun you don't pick
between these things but obviously I
said know how to spend your money it's
one of those things where you I'm sure
people will start to get into a routine
you can set up these traps like turrets
right here you can kind of see on the
wall behind him all these wire trails
destroy them right there but yeah you
would start opening up more of the
basement and getting other scrap benches
there's two scrapped benches at least
that I found I think that's all there is
that you can actually build them but
that lock door right there there's
another compactor behind it it it was
fun I actually really liked it for
different reasons and I liked the main
game there are a lot of enemies in
nightmare compared to the main game but
I really do like it I think it's worth
the $10 if you haven't if you've beaten
resonable 7 it did come out I think I
like the idea that they're trying to be
you know the for honor release coming up
on Valentine's Day the horizon on the
28th two weeks after rather you know
like they're not competing with anything
at the moment really
man you got a neo next week if you don't
know it's like the Japanese Miss
oriented a kind
Dark Souls our scheme and I'm not just
comparing it to Dark Souls like we
compare everything to darks a little bit
it's like actually like variables yes I
am Miguel Kentucky I was playing through
the problem is pretty tough
his review will be up that's like a very
hardly moving progress very different
style of game obviously yeah again the
competition yeah so if you are
interested Neil
to know that review will be up tomorrow
morning but we do a lot of reading with
seven footage up but I just want to get
into questions about the band footage I
don't know if you guys had any other
things you're curious about uh not a
whole lot do you think you think you'll
play in your basement golly ah yeah my
rooms in the basement I'm really
paranoid that people are going to look
at me through the window because it's
like ground level so maybe not yeah
but the psvr is in the living room so I
might just do that instead and use that
as my excuse like oh I want to play on
VR yeah there yeah there's something
about those scenes were you I mean I
guess I don't want to spoil it but she
like well she she's like you know your
pretty girl like yeah that'd be alright
like you're locked up and you're being
force-fed body parts
I was going to bring that up when I say
I did a couple of the demos in VR and
when they're like force-feeding you it's
horrible and physically I moved out of
range I think like I moved so far back
but it didn't work anymore and I had to
like recalibrate not good did not enjoy
that I mean I did and I didn't because
it was like cool and gross oh but her
face is horrible you got to think of the
game overall so far I like it all I
think you and I talked about this about
the not like sort of not somatically but
there you feel the classic Resident Evil
kind of spirit flowing through it we
talked about that a little bit and
that's what I liked about it I like that
there's some of that I like that it's
actually scary like me terrified okay
yeah yeah I agree
sorry one more quick before the stage
from the chat this is going to make no
sense if you're watching this breakout
on YouTube but Eric Green said rob is
Central Perk from France where everyone
wants to be or maybe all his friends
want to crawl inside them Rob you're
hating that so much and that's why I'm
enjoying it so much great yeah we target
a friend geo from earlier the show yeah
anyway now yeah touching back the year I
find the jump scares to be not cheap
right like there's one in the beginning
where you know it's again it got me so
good and I'm actually a pretty big
scaredy-cat and I will yell and it was
like 1:00 2:00 a.m. my roommate was like
dude will you shut up because I'm just
it's not just like a yell it's like a
sentence I'm yelling like but it's you
know it's there well done and respect
that like they come at you when you're
the most vulnerable or are in how you're
feeling is the most surprising like I
think I was telling you guys like you
they got me so good when I had just done
something like it was leading up to like
an accomplishment and I was like oh
great like I'm doing pretty good in this
game and right as you're hitting that
feeling jump-scare
and that's when it got me so good I was
just screaming and that's fun I like I
have a go weird like I want to say
relationship with like horror movies I
just don't know like sometimes it says I
hate the ones worth like I'm just up all
night thinking about said movie yeah I
can't go to sleep someone's in your room
about to kill you right yeah I think I
was scared of the ring for like 10
straight years when I wash it again I
was like what less care that I do oh
sorry oh no no I'll just say The
Exorcist is my the movie that has
haunted me forever
okay really again yep it's one of my
favorite movies and I can't watch
anymore I can't handle Chucky like the
doll really I don't know why I just
can't and they made it be shoujo figure
of Chucky like it's a little it's
horrible
hate it Oh anyway I meant to ask you
Mike because I've been curious about
this you are easily startled mm-hmm I
would say I think everyone could agree
on that yes how do you and you really
like horror and I'm just really curious
how that works it's more I don't know
it's kind of masochistic I guess but
although I don't I don't know I I don't
I don't have anything against jump
scares but here's like a adrenaline high
yeah we're in there like maybe it is
sort of like I appreciate horror more
when it's more dread and tension
and disturbing than jumpscares yeah I
like red legal 7or that's why I used to
like resin evil seven or resonable 3
nemesis because it's thing hunting you
the whole time and nemesis and then I
replayed it with Mary Kish and I don't
like that game anymore
like I think it's bad ish I think it's
an okay game that's a separate
conversation but we I'm going to plug it
quick Mary Kish and I play through all
the resonable games on the resident evil
but uh there's a lot of resin content we
have up but I don't know maybe it is
like masochistic or the adrenaline rush
of horror
I appreciate like good horror movies
that actually like I said increase the
dread like it follows one my favorite
horror movies I love it follows yeah and
I like the idea that it's not you know
there are a couple of jump scares but
it's but it's there earned
really when I the beach okay anymore
yeah from or the the bedroom door is
that a yes it is good but uh yeah I
don't know I don't I don't scare too
easily in terms of like I jump scare
easily if I don't scare it too easily in
terms of actually getting creeped out or
not that cool or doesn't bother me were
you scared a lot in this game like we
jumping around Hill seven yeah um yes
there were a couple times being chased
in this game which is something I think
outlast and from what I played about
less - they do really well in the terror
of being chased knowing someone's right
behind you especially cuz Jack Baker in
this game oh yeah
there's there's someone that chases you
in the DLC that's it's way faster than
you are
so it's terrifying all right you'd never
know that so that's why VR I think works
really well with this game because it
feels like they're right behind you not
just you know right behind Ethan the
character or anything and yeah like 0hx
CEO side was saying psychological horror
is the best horror I totally agree the
stuff that actually can mess with you
mentally is my favorite i watch the
wailing no um it was the 2016 Korean
horror film that one was super
psychological and it's like two and a
half hours or something and I just
thought about it for the next two days
yeah when I would recommend Eric Green
again the one who compares you to
Central Perk I believe who's saying
green room had some body for that stuck
me a few days green rooms really good
that's more that's less like horror but
it's more like gore and like super kind
of realistic looking violence but anyway
ready will seven I completely recommend
this DLC if you've been
or if you'd like keep it in your mind
while you're beating resonable 7i it's
got a lot of good variety we might be
doing more extensive write-up I'm not
completely sure I think Scott waterworks
wants to check it out at some point see
what he wants to do and keep running
reviews editor will be the one to make
that call but we have a lot of resonable
7 content up right now we have reviving
Resident Evil are UK team and myself
traveled to Japan that Capcom semi
recently a couple months ago to do it
behind the scenes documentary about
resin evil 7 and also how it influenced
like indie horror and how indie or
horror influenced this is the newest
game and how the series kind of declined
until now we do have another thing that
you Jake and I are working on kind of
semi soonish about resonable 7 and
silent hills and whatnot so yeah just go
over to GameSpot we have a lot of good
regular selling content up and we read
the comments so leave your thoughts and
we will respond to them when we get the
chance
[Music]